hey guys how's it going today it is very
cold in Los Angeles last week it was I
kid you not
113 degrees and that was in Anaheim and
this here is an iPhone 10 vlog guys LA
has seasons look I just adjusted the
color so when I clicked on the sky look
how good that looks
you do look pretty good that's good a
nice shot ready I'm not looking at the
camera see this is me looking at the
camera and this is me looking at the
screen cool let's start this I click me
this is the back camera we're hiking up
to this mountain I'm so excited for this
drone shot I've been thinking about this
shot whenever I first wrote the vo for
this video and I was like this is what I
want and this morning I woke up it was
raining I was like Jenna know the shot
so that's the hill huh right there
he's in samarkand aw hell we're zoomed
in by success all right there
you just wanna scape go I just tried
you've got back
I'm looking for is I'm holding up the
phone and then you're gonna like fly
away it'll be a close-up shot of it okay
we don't know much time it's getting
dark
[Music]
my first blog on the iPhone she let me
have it because she's occupied I am
occupied I can say my eyes off the drill
you can't take my snap the drum for this
muffler coming in I'm like look how fast
[Music]
I'm so cold I'm shaking we're walking
down oh no we're gonna get dinner on
Third Street Promenade check out the
Apple store where I slept outside for
the iPhone 6 that was probably the
craziest thing I think that I have ever
done although I have stayed up so late
editing iPhone videos this week that I
think I felt better sleeping outside
waiting for the phone that I did
shooting and editing all of these videos
this week I don't do well if I don't get
a lot of sleep and I don't eat well and
I've just been like snacking and
drinking coffee and yerba mate a we
gotta go I'm cold please hurry
Jenna playing trivia for low-light
optical image stabilization let's talk
about it okay guess not bye Jen okay
just the line is this it there's people
did put them in the middle yes that's
right they moved us from over here to
over here everybody weight ins morrow
morning it's gonna be the best day and
there's the apple start tomorrow Jenna
we're not camping out tomorrow morning
will be the release on our own time oh
I'm so excited you guys remember when we
slept out this is where we slept for
over 55 hours we were here a while
probably for like 40 we were here and
then they moved us over here so the best
part is in 2010 I said I will never be
first in line for an iPhone video and
then here I was 2000 2014
2014 is that when we slept out um I
don't know yet so yeah
2014 this is monumental so you are first
in line first in line
okay introduce yourself what's up guys
I'm Jake I just moved to LA from New
York I got here 10:30 this morning after
watching Justine's old video I can't
believe it I'm first in line for the new
iPhone I was just talking about it over
here so what's your channel you make
youtube videos as well I make youtube
videos it's like kind of a mix of
everything a little bit of blah
I do Jiu Jitsu a little bit of tech
videos I'm just a techie but I'm not as
well-versed as like Justine or marques
you're first in line it's the first of
this is monumental I mean this is like
the 10th anniversary all and this is one
second nothing with you she's the one
who sold me the winners from the iPhone
slo-mo video oh my god so great here
you're gonna camp out too
no thankfully oh yeah oh my pre-order
it's a mail we got first in line oh my
goodness you're so excited I'm so
excited to check out your channel and
you're gonna wait while you're filming
she has another great story
remember when I went to YouTube back in
at the teachers compete sense to give
you the people in line and I'm having
Jenna film because I can't have my phone
out in line people that are waiting for
the phone so I'm hiding the phone we're
gonna go back and we're gonna give them
some pizzas I remember when we were
camping out that getting food wasn't the
best part of the day and these people
are hungry they need a snack in the shop
every trip once
but you smell so nice like wafting in my
in my face with those feet those smells
really good that I messed up I should
have got pizza we should have a big back
not like a nice healthy salmon salad
this is what I want okay I'll try to
hide this clearly
my kids know
[Music]
all right the first in line and what
number you doesn't even matter but they
got me thought we were gonna head home
and I've been out of this video and
tomorrow morning the iPhone titled early
[Applause]
[Music]